[Music]
I never realized how much I missed the
Chinese Theater is amazing the history
have him here and now to show it in imax
and 3d the ultimate format to see the
movie in as the ultimate premiere
experience of the director of the dream
come here and the cajun second the
sponsors are doing in here are amazing
that action is amazing storylines
amazing if there ever was a place and
see this movie its up on imax because
going on a roller coaster ride I think
that the audience is going to go crazy
over the fact that it's a movie that
you're allowed to have fun in the
imagery is the music like the three
dimensionality of it is he's getting the
middle leader especially you can hear
coming from all with the goal of the
back and concentrate good your three
Pratley completely insane what you want
I got what you need it's not just an der
anymore there's a hold of the crew it's
a global cast it's an amazing cast we
have Donnie yeah Nia you kept a cathode
you have Ruby Rose you have this great
global cast and it's sort of it's not
only Xander who's doing all this crazy
stuff but there's a bunch of people in
kind of come in the phone still
shouldn't make that work I think they're
going to love the big accident
people saying that they want to see it
again in the guy gave it to Jen joking
for gonna come up short positioning
you're not making me breakfast in life
there's a particular motorcycle sequence
in the water where motorcycles actually
go into the ocean and drive on the water
and riding waves which is really
exciting in imax and there's a really
amazing sort of zero-g fight that
happens on a c-17 and seeing that in the
imax 3d experience the open there's a
big buzz around this movie so hopefully
people get out and clean little bit
successful escape I think because it's
like an explosive film anyway I mean
overall experience the movie is amazing
I I can't wait gonna be fun
so but [ __ ] so much eye candy up there
and going so fast that you can't really
take it all in and looking fit and I'm
out damn it feels good to be back
you
you